und ganz am anfang möchte ich ihnen
einmal zeigen was die stunde offenbar
geschlagen hat denn so ging es uns als
wir das gehört haben was michael
kretschmer der ministerpräsident von
sachsen-anhalt gesagt hat
der satz die pandemische lage ist
beendet von nationaler tragweite ist
beendet ist nicht nur kolossal falsch er
hat auch einen gewaltigen schaden
angerichtet es ist meine damen und
herren die letzte ausfahrt jetzt kommt
vor einem blog down glauben sie mir ich
weiß wovon ich spreche wenn das jetzt
nicht funktioniert dauert es noch einige
wochen und dann werden auch in berlin
diese ganzen leute die jetzt sagen was
alles nicht geht was sie alles nicht für
notwendig halten von den realitäten in
den krankenhäusern eingeholt werden
diese ganzen leute in berlin frauchen
mit damit ist ganz sicher glaube ich
auch ihr fdp chef christian lindner
gemeint der ja bei uns sind bild in der
vergangenen woche gesagt hat lockdown
mit der ampel das wird es auf keinen
fall geben ist das ein versprechen was
möglicherweise auch wieder kassiert
werden muss wenn die jetzigen modelle
nicht funktionieren nein wir brauchen
dringend glaubwürdigkeit und wir haben
heute eine völlig andere situation wie
vor einem jahr die politik hat auch in
den letzten monaten vieles richtig
gemacht wir kommen gut mit den in vier
schritten voran und deswegen darf es
keinen grundsätzlichen lockdown mehr
geben aber warum ist das nicht
vergleichbar mit dem letzten jahr wenn
wir uns das anhören was aus den kliniken
kommt was die intensivmediziner sagen
dann sagen sie die situation ist sehr
wohl vergleichbar insbesondere in der
belastung und vor allem auch dadurch
dass es weniger krankenschwestern
pflegern und so weiter gibt also die
schlagen jetzt alarm und machen alle wir
haben eine völlig andere situation weil
heute jede bürgerin jedem bürger auch
ein impf angebot unterbreitet werden
kann bekommen beim impfen deutlich voran
und deswegen müssen wir lernen das haben
wir auch in den letzten monaten getan
mit anderen instrumenten zu agieren und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt
weg von diesen pauschalen maßnahmen
ausgangssperre lockdown
schulschließungen pauschal hinzu konkret
also los genauen möglich die lotter und
für immer ausgeschlossen ja klare ansage
aus rheinland pfalz von daniela schmid
der fdp wirtschaftsministerin vergassen
sie als chef der kassen ärzte sie haben
ja auch immer gegen panikmache gewütet
und gesagt so dramatisch ist die lage
nicht wenn wir uns unterhalten haben in
den vergangenen monaten was die zahlen
angeht zu diesem zeitpunkt noch vor
allem im sommer wenn sie jetzt die
öffentliche debatte sehen glauben sie
das ist wie herr kretschmann sagt wieder
zu einem lockdown kommen könnte oder
glauben sie frau schmidt die sagt lock
down auf keinen fall
also da bin ich schonmal frau schmidt
ich glaube in london wird es nicht mehr
geben und ich glaube werden auch keinen
mehr brauchen herr kretschmann ist
natürlich beeindruckt von der situation
in sachsen die zugegebenermaßen nicht
mit dem bundesdurchschnitt vergleichbar
ist relativ schlechte ihm später hohe
inzidenz zahlen als es ja leider ein
problem was ich in sachsen schon seit
monaten zeigt aber es ist natürlich
nicht die situation ist eine andere wir
haben immer in eine
durchimpfung der erwachsenen bevölkerung
die wenn man jetzt nicht auf ein prozent
genau schaut weil die zahlen ja nicht
ganz von der prozent stellen werden wir
um die 80 prozent der erwachsenen
gekämpft haben über alles knapp 68 das
ist schon mal ein pfund auch wenn wir
jetzt bei den alten und
immungeschwächten sicherlich nachlegen
müssen und postern aber natürlich ist
das nicht mehr vergleichbar mit den mit
der situation vor einem jahr und sehen
uns die grundintention anschauen sind
sie natürlich auch getrieben von extrem
hohen instanzen bei den kindern da wird
ja auch regelmäßig getestet so dass wir
hier sicherlich auch ein etwas falsches
bild